are the feds gonna use this crypto crash
here is justification to jump in here
and ruin the whole market
oh absolutely the fed will use any
excuse any emergency to um you know use
their claws and try and take control but
ultimately nothing is systematically
wrong bitcoin is working perfectly fine
we have to realize that we've just had a
two-year bull market nothing goes up
forever and ultimately if you look at
the last two years bitcoin is up 700
outperforming most traditional asset
classes including gold which is actually
down this weekend down below one
thousand eight hundred dollars raising
all year-to-date gains and we have to
realize that the bull market was very
much driven by the fed flooding the
system with money people were putting
their stimulus checks into bitcoin we're
now seeing astronomical levels of
inflation people simply can't afford to
be investing in alternative asset
classes they need to be putting that
money into you know living essentially
also it's important to consider the
geopolitical situation bitcoin isn't yet
an uncorrelated asset it is only 13
years old it is that risk on asset so
naturally people are going to sell their
riskiest assets but overall bitcoin is
doing exactly what it's designed to do i
can still trade money i can still send
you money it's still decentralized and
it's still immune from government
corruption